let's jump to this next story because
I've been sitting on this one we got
this from The Daily Mail AOC says that
gas stoves are linked to reduced
cognitive performance in spat with
Republican Ronnie Jackson after he said
he would never give his up you may have
heard the news the body Administration
wants to ban gas stoves this is a psyop
sort of here's what happens the bite
Administration consumer protection group
literally says on TV we want to
potentially ban gas stoves CNN and the
Washington Post then report definitively
they want to ban gas stoves huge
backlash ensues politicians and
personalities like AOC come out and say
well gas stoves are bad and there's
indoor pollution
then the backlash gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and they look really stupid
and they're pissing people off so they
issue a statement saying no no no no no
no we never wanted to ban gas stoves
you're all crazy Snopes then issues a
story does the Biden Administration want
to ban gas stoves false and now anybody
who claimed they did is going to look
stupid they're reversing someone posted
on Twitter it's a trial balloon they say
something and if the backlash is too big
they walk it back yeah same with the
invasion of Syria that's what Obama did
because people were like hell no we're
not going to war in Syria they didn't
invade they like to see how far they can
get or what they can get away with you
know or it's just they try to do it and
they were forced to pull back right so
it's like that story we talk about where
eBay had a yellow website and then
wanted to be white but then everybody
got mad when they changed it from yellow
to White so then they changed it back
and then every day they slowly
incremented the shade one degree and
then a year later the website was white
nobody cared really I think Cortez said
that they're gonna Alex AOC said that
they're gonna not ban gas stoves but
start only after 20 30 be creating
electric stoves from here on out and no
new apartments will have anything other
than electricity well many states have
already implemented a lot of these very
similar policies I think New York and
California already have it where if
you're building a building you cannot
have a gas stove inside of it so that
already is very disproportionately
attacking a lot of ethnic communities
especially that make their own food in
their own kind of specific way using a
fire in order to do so and when you use
electric this is this is going to mean
that we're going to of course use more
electricity which is going to hurt the
grid which California already is dealing
with a very serious problem with why are
they doing this are they trying to
deliberately destroy our our energy
sector yes yes also I like electric
better than gas I I like gas better
because you can pick up the pan and turn
it sideways and get heat all over the
pan to get a more even cook no you can
do that with electric no because if you
lift it up you lose the heat you can
turn it sideways and you can keep
touching it and the problem with uh it's
have you ever felt near the electricity
the problem with gas in my opinion is
that the fire moves and it creates an
uneven cook no matter what that's fun
that's the fun part you see that's
working with the fire see I like a
consistent stable even cook and you like
chaos I think that it's more consistent
with fire because you can get the sides
and stuff I like the chaos I'm what you
eat when my pan is on Full contact with
the electric that bacon Cooks perfectly
all around
I think for more Exquisite long-term
Cooks you want you want to be able to
mediate your temperature at will like in
a split second you want to go do that on
electric what are you talking about well
you gotta go you want it 70 degrees
cooler than you want it 45 degrees
cooler over here and you want to I don't
think so because if you pick it up to
shake it around you lose the content
flat disc of heat that you can move in
any direction you want with fire the
fire is going all crazy and all over
that but you have no idea the point is
you got to maintain con physical contact
with the electric element because if you
lift it up oh you don't yeah otherwise
even if you're working with like walks
right which a lot of people in the Asian
communities are you need a fire you
can't have an electric okay a problem is
people will use wood they'll end up
using dirtier things than gas if they
don't have access to Flame that's what
I'm concerned yeah yeah do you want good
Chinese food or crappy Chinese food I
want good Chinese food I will not walk
in there I want that Rice prepared nice
and makes a good point people in rural
areas without access to gas will start
burning wood yeah and that is so dirty
yeah that's what happened in South
Africa man all the all the gas became uh
I don't remember the whole story but
basically using fire and it depleted all
of the natural forests in the area
because they just used it to make fire
to warm their houses and the carbon is
going to put all that carbon yeah which
is terrible for your lungs and on top of
that if your power goes out and you have
an electric stove good luck getting some
heat to light a fire to warm yourself up
if it's in the middle of the winter at
least back in the day you had a gas
thing you could get the element on light
a candle on fire yeah for me this is
happening in order to push the kind of
digitization of everything to to fully
have a technocratic society you need
everyone dependent on technology and if
you're able to cut off that technology
you're able to control people more and
and cutting people's ability to heat
their own food by just simply clicking a
button that could be easily done with
this new policy and I think that's why
they're really doing it in my opinion
yeah I mean I personally prefer electric
but I don't want them to eliminate the
gas because of this reason exactly I
mean I really don't think we're far from
like a social credit score you know what
we see in China like and I really think
the the with the push for electric
everything electric cars especially
um you know and now this and everything
else oh you liked gays for groomers no
cooking friends oh your Tesla is also
going to be against groomers yes by the
way sorry sorry
it's proper grooming goodness let's talk
about grooming so no you know what I
tell groomers like actual pet groomers
that they should just refer to
themselves as pet stylists from now on
because if they if they ban gas stoves
Nationwide that means rural people won't
have access and a lot of those people
have gas tanks at their houses which
would put their cooking on the grid and
the grid can be controlled by external
forces so it's it's just centralization
just like electric cars you know I think
yeah it'll never be another reason you
have a kill switch which a lot of
governments are working on especially in
Europe right now where they could just
turn off your car whenever they want to
it's so scary it's freakish dude yeah I
want to get a heating element on my
phone on the new Android model where I
can like a cigarette lighter push a
button and it'll heat up oh they have
those I'm pretty sure oh good yeah hell
yeah yeah I think they have those I
think I saw that get me off the grid of
course they can shut my phone off if
they wanted that's why they track you
Ian with the cell phone but you can also
get solar the problem with solar systems
is they're also hooked to the grid yeah
so if this system like if if anything
did happen where they're trying to
control everything you'd have to create
your own electrical grid like small one
off the grid like we have the we have
the van that has its own electrical
system I can I can plug into it without
having to worry about anything but even
our solar system which is like we
generate our own electricity with solar
panels we have to get permission from
the grid to activate can you plug the RV
into the grid as well as have it off
grid yes that's cool yes Shore power so
you can actually sync the battery up to
the grid if you want and that doesn't
you don't need permission for that you
just plug it in but like a big solar
system before we can even turn it on we
gotta the government has to come into an
inspection and all that stuff I know
methane's dirty I know that and you
don't want to breathe in direct methane
obviously you cook with a ventilation
system but I mean what's the the other
options is burning wood I mean that's
the reality of it is everybody's yelling
at me saying that gas is the way to go
I'm just saying when I'm cooking bacon I
got this nice even cook on the bacon
it's done super quick and I gotta worry
I want to give a special shout out to
Chef Andrew gruel he's being extreme
extremely vocal about this and making
noise going on TV he was talking about
this on the show before this even became
an issue if you remember that time he
came on the broadcast it was a great
podcast you haven't listened to it check
it out uh how do you say his name again
uh Andrew gruel I believe how do you
spell it g-r-u-e-l yeah that was a great
podcast and he and he was warning about
that very specific issue and now now
it's here he's a professional chef yeah
he's awesome
and then he could and he cooked for us
oh that was great I enjoyed we have we
have an electric downstairs and I'm
always sad about it I'm always wishing I
had an open flame well I have another
one we'll make a Brickwood oven yeah a
freedom stand that's how you do it we'll
throw some wood in there and then some
charcoal wood a little natural wood you
go to the forest you'll get your own
wood get a little carbon there's
probably a bunch of trees that already
fell down you'll chop them up and you'll
do the work Ian I'm into it to convert
the energy I gotta get a really nice
chainsaw you ever use a chainsaw I
haven't but you know what this is a
random side note I used to be well not
long ago I was really into bush craft so
like this all sounds really fun to me I
never got into it but like I would watch
endless hours of Bushcraft videos on
YouTube it was like relaxing to me and I
was thinking like why am I so into this
and I think maybe my subconscious was
like to prepare you like you might need
these skills sometime in the near future
but no but that sounds fun to me I'd be
I'd be totally game for that I was
watching the island uh with what is it
Bear Grylls did you guys ever see that
show a couple years ago the island where
I don't know something that's called the
island where they go 12 14 people on an
island trying to survive men versus
women last night I was just a pouring
over episode after episode of it uh same
thing I've got this fascination with the
Survival Life although I'm
grateful for the things I have the
really famous ones where they have the
men and women separate yeah the men like
within 10 minutes have like a
functioning Society that's how I fell
into it I was watching women are lost
walking around that's transphobic
there's numerous episodes of these shows
and it's like it's almost like there are
differences between the sex is it's like
the guys have like a cabana and they're
like serving drinks yeah there was one I
watched I think it was Bear Grylls where
like the women kept going in circles
that's the one I watched last night and
they were crying for days yeah after
days they couldn't find their base camp
so the girls at the base camp were just
like they've abandoned us oh my God for
three days three twice or three times
they were going inside
but what got me there was I was watching
Andrew Tate's stuff about misogyny and
then they were like oh yeah our men and
women even is good at survival and then
I was like well let's watch this thing
so you watch some entertain content I've
been really diving deep on the Andrew
Tate stuff lately Destiny and um Pearl
uh oh yeah just Pearl just pearly things
did uh did a episode about it today that
came out did you guys I have like no
interest in the Andrew Tate Saga what do
you get what's your vibe from a distance
I mean I think he's a
you know piece of I don't know what if I
can I can't swear whatever I don't think
he's a good guy I don't like him I don't
like his method obviously you know I'm
anti-matrix you know his whole thing
with the Matrix which I think the way he
just markets that is very corny
um but you know there's I just feel bad
that these are this this is one of the
role models uh the most prominent role
models for like young men in our society
like I just think they deserve better
but um I'm not a fan personally and I
just I I don't keep up with the drama of
it right personally I'm with you I want
to like him because of some of the stuff
he said but right it just is well broken
you know yeah I agree with some of the
stuff he said I just I don't like him I
think he's a sleazy character
um obviously you know he's stringing
these young men along promising them
great things like to be to make
something great out of themselves and
honestly you know I I watched I did
watch one video kind of on his tenants
program or whatever like the Matrix I
don't even know what it's called but
like you join this program and he's
basically you know promising to to teach
you how to achieve Financial Freedom and
like own 10 Lamborghinis like him or
whatever and it's basically just like a
basic you know Shopify 101 course yeah
you know and like it teaches you drop
shipping which you could learn for free
on YouTube in like a day yeah so I don't
know I don't like people that take
advantage of you know people it's do you
think just you should be impressed and
wait for the evidence until you think
that oh definitely evidence wait for the
evidence I mean I think that in order to
hold him like he says that the Matrix is
against him I don't know I think that
you know I do remember he put out that
he he was on some podcast or whatever
and kind of primered it that like you
know they're coming after me just
because I'm so successful and I'm
breaking the Matrix and whatever so
they're gonna arrest me I think you
probably knew that something was coming
down the pipeline and so he put that out
as kind of like you know to set the
stage for it basically and like he
didn't do anything wrong because they're
just out to get him like he planted that
idea but I'm sure there is evidence like
I'm sure there is something but I am not
going to judge him until that's fully
known exactly I think he admitted to
most a lot of it which is like I don't
know if you would call what he did what
he admitted to sex trafficking I'm not
sure the exact definition of sex
trafficking but if you if you invite a
woman out to work for you uh and then or
you invite a woman out because because
she's in love with you and then she gets
there and you're like by the way why
don't you start doing this cam work for
me is that is that no that's not what it
is it's that you say I love you come
work with me we're gonna do this thing
and then when she gets there you're like
if you don't do it I'm kicking you out
and taking your money away forcing her
into the position pull the rug but but
here's the issue I see with Tate is
because I've been looking at a lot of
stuff as well and some of it I really do
feel like you guys ever see that movie
um the life of David Gale yeah I love
that movie it's really good that is such
an underrated movie Yes Kevin Spacey was
it was okay that's right that's right it
was so great in that all right so
basically what happens is this professor
is at a party he sees this uh this young
woman who got like expelled or something
and then she's like let's go in the
bathroom and hook up and then she says
like be rough with me and then he's like
Bangor and then she's like rip him off
rip off my panties and then he rips him
off and then she's like yeah yeah and
then she scratches him and he's like
yeah then she says he raped her ripped
her clothes off and she scratched him in
self-defense making it look like she
planned the whole thing so the reason I
brought that up is not that I'm saying
Andrew Tate is necessarily being falsely
accused but I'm wondering when you look
at a lot of these quotes and I'm like it
sounds like they were Kink playing when
he's like when he says things that are
so over like I was reading one quote
where it's like according to a
transcript he was saying like oh yes
baby I enjoy raping you this is so good
I was like this would actually sound
real man no it's a little incriminating
don't you say right right but like
there's that viral video where
apparently he's like beating a woman and
the woman said that they were just like
they're they were it was kink like she
wanted him to be rough and she was
totally into it but they what they do is
they take it out of context and they
make it seem like you shouldn't be
allowed to do those things now I'm not
trying to defend the guy saying he
didn't do these things I'm just saying
some of them are so over the top I have
to wonder if like he's just playing oh
if there's ever going to be false
allegations against Andrew Tate now is
the time for them to come out and well
some of the people what they're
suggesting is that one of the girls that
was working for him got really loud
mouth smashing stuff up kind of person
and then she went and kind of caused
this big scene and then other people
kind of piled on
um that's one suggestion but you know
well this has been an ongoing
investigation since April so we're gonna
see what the Romanian authorities kind
of put out there uh so far I mean we got
some text messages from Vice that were
you know allegedly reduplicated uh who
knows what the whole conversation was
really about what they only show oh
Andrew texting but not the responses
what was the response what was the
conversation I'm waiting to to find out
more before making any kind of judgment
calls but uh whatever people think both
scenarios could be true here it could be
you know the Matrix or whatever you call
it and he could be a bad guy it could be
both it could be one of them it could be
neither of them who knows uh let's wait
until we actually see the real evidence
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time